You know him as the Pumpkin King and
you definitely don't know him as Sandy
Claws — but what do only adults
notice about Jack Skellington?
Jack Skellington is known as the Pumpkin King
— but what does that title actually mean? Jack
certainly isn't a monarch, and Halloween Town
already has a leader: its two-faced mayor. Sure,
Jack helps organize the spooking and scaring
that takes place on Halloween and gives some
great speeches along the way, but it's tough
to say what exactly he does for an actual job.
So he's a leader who holds no real political
power, he supposedly has a knack for motivating
people, and he's a consultant to the
powers-that-be… yet it's hard to put
your finger on what exactly he does for a
"real" job. It seems like Jack Skellington
is basically Halloween Town's version of the
British royal family. Jack truly is royalty as
his title implies, and his status is complete
with the abject boredom that you'd expect from
someone who exists to be a figurehead. No
wonder he's jealous of the hardworking,
much-credited Santa Claus. At least
Santa actually gets to do something.
While Tim Burton wrote his delightfully
creepy poem, The Nightmare Before Christmas,
all the way back in 1982, the first
Hollywood feature film to truly nail
the director's trademark spooky aesthetic
wouldn't come until 1988, with Beetlejuice.
"It's showtime."
Many of the details in Beetlejuice are
similar to elements of The Nightmare
Before Christmas. When Geena Davis and Alec
Baldwin are brought back in the séance scene,
for example, their faces have the same
distinct, wrinkly lines seen on the faces
of the dead in Halloween Town. Beetlejuice
uses games as a way to torture the people,
similar to Oogie Boogie's antagonism toward
Jack Skellington and Santa Claus. And the
statues coming to life in Beetlejuice are echoed
by the kids' walking bathtub in Nightmare. There's
even a ghostly hat decoration in Beetlejuice
that looks eerily similar to Jack Skellington.
When Beetlejuice finally gets to have his fun
and haunt the humans, he appears wearing a
distinctive hat. At the top is a man with
a hollow-eyed skull in a familiar shape,
adorned by a bat that looks a lot like
Jack's bowtie. Whether this hat topper is
based on Burton's idea for Jack Skellington or the
other way around, the resemblance is unmistakable.
Jack's black-and-white suit looks like it's
glued on, and getting it on and off must be
a straight-up nightmare. Moreover, when
Jack's Santa suit is destroyed when his
sled is blown up by the military later
in the movie, it's revealed that he was
"wearing" his pinstripe suit under the
Santa suit the whole time. Therefore,
it would seem Jack never takes his suit
off — and we don't know if he actually can.
If he can't, that would make sense for more
than just aesthetic reasons. Getting back
to the fact that Jack is a skeleton, and
skeletons are held together by soft tissue
that eventually rots away, you could argue
that he would fall apart without his suit.
Obviously, there's already a lot of suspension of
disbelief that needs to occur in order to accept
most of what we see in Halloween Town. Yet it
would make sense that Jack's suit also serves
the purpose of keeping his bones together, just
like skin keeps our insides from falling out.
In a sense, Jack Skellington has black-and-white
pinstriped skin — like some sort of bipedal zebra.
Why does Jack task Lock, Shock, and Barrel with
kidnapping the holiday icon he mistakenly refers
to as "Sandy Claws"? Even more alarmingly, why
does he assume that the kids, also referred
to as "Boogie's Boys," wouldn't go right to
Oogie Boogie and spill the beans? Seriously,
for a character who's so smart that the Mayor
needs his guidance on the yearly Halloween plans,
you've got to wonder: Why would Jack ever
trust these impish trick-or-treaters?
For one thing, they're not the sharpest tools
in the shed, since they accidentally kidnap
the Easter Bunny instead of Santa. Secondly,
everybody in Halloween Town loves Jack and
holds him in the highest esteem: Surely he
could have found an eager and loyal helper
anywhere else? So why would he instead
pick three kids who, at best, treat him
with amused disdain? It's not like Jack doesn't
know about their association with Oogie Boogie.
"And one more thing… leave that no
account Oogie Boogie out of this!"
So he knows where their true loyalties
lie but decides to count on them anyway.
It seems that Jack isn't as clever as
the residents of Halloween Town think.
As he sings the number "Jack's Lament," Jack
removes his head, holding it out like Hamlet
holds the exhumed jester Yorick's skull while
reciting his famous "Alas, poor Yorick" speech.
The fact that Jack is a skeleton, and can
therefore bend the rules of his anatomy,
allows him to embody both Yorick and Hamlet
in the recreation of this Shakespearean scene.
While this self-decapitation lasts just for
a moment during Jack's sweeping song about
identity and futility, it speaks very strongly
to who Jack really is. One part of him is Hamlet,
full of ennui and self-doubt, wondering at the
purpose of his existence. But another part of him
is the jester Yorick, the silly fool who can make
you laugh and cry, who can tumble and fall and get
back up with a big smile. In this one moment,
Jack shows just how complicated he truly is.
In animation, nearly every detail on screen is
drawn on purpose, and this goes especially for
a movie produced by a man known for crafting
a very specific, detailed aesthetic style. In
The Nightmare Before Christmas, Jack Skellington's
hands show the joints between his knuckles, which
makes sense, as this emphatic leader is big on
hand gestures and physical articulation. But if he
needs joints to move his fingers, how does he move
his neck? That looks like one single fused bone
rather than a stack of vertebrae. Sure, it has
wrinkles, but there don't appear to be any joints.
Based simply on how skeletons work,
Jack's neck couldn't bend, twist,
and turn without vertebrae — after all,
bones don't move and bend themselves,
but instead achieve mobility through the
combined efforts of their muscles and
joints. How does the ever-introspective Jack
bend his neck in contemplation and wonderment,
then? Such deep questions, hard-hitting
and poignant, may never be answered.
Disney had some serious apprehensions about
producing The Nightmare Before Christmas as a
children's movie. Their concerns about the horror
elements led Disney to release the film under the
company's "grown-up" subsidiary, Touchstone
Pictures, instead of the main Disney label.
"How horrible our Christmas will be."
"No, how jolly!"
The entertainment giant also requested
a few changes. For example, Disney execs
demanded that Jack Skellington
should have eyes in his sockets.
They say the eyes are the windows to the soul, a
fountain of emotion that allows people to relate
to each other — so perhaps Disney was worried
that Jack would seem lacking in personality
without them. Or maybe the studio was worried
that Jack Skellington would look too sinister
for younger audiences. Luckily, producer-creator
Tim Burton and director Henry Selick stood their
ground on the point that Jack is, in fact,
a skeleton, and skeletons don't have eyes.
It's a good thing they stood strong too,
because Jack, now a beloved character,
doesn't seem to have suffered any kind of hit for
having empty eye sockets. In fact, his face is so
expressive that kids may not even notice that
he has no eyes — even if Disney definitely did.
Of course, people emote with more than just their
eyes. For example, a fair bit of emotion comes
across in the eyebrows and the mouth. Without
eyes, Jack has to depend even more on these kinds
of facial reactions. The only problem with this,
of course, is that skulls can't actually move.
Muscles and skin create the appearance of brows
going up or down, as well as contorting the lips
into a smile or a grimace. The human skull doesn't
move in real life, since bone is solid. Certainly,
there has to be some artistic license at play
to give a skeleton without eyes some semblance
of emotion, and, to that end, the animators afford
Jack's skeletal face the same flexibility he would
have if it were covered in skin. It's almost
as if Jack Skellington's skull is made of clay.
There are some weird things going on with
Jack Skellington, anatomically speaking.
One aspect of his body that draws a critical
eye is that his mouth appears to be stitched
together… except when it's not. The lines
running up and down Jack's face could be
seen simply as stylized wrinkly lips at first,
like the remnants of flesh in a state of decay.
But if you look toward the back of Jack's skull,
his mouth looks like it's just sewn together.
When you think about it, this makes sense:
There are no muscles to hold the bottom
and top of his jaw in place. When closed,
his mouth looks like it's strung together. When
open, it's as if the threads have magically split,
except towards the back, where they hold the
hinges of the jaw together. So you can probably
add another unique feature to Jack's anatomy:
Apparently, string can be sewn through his bone
to take the place of muscles and tendons.
Jack Skellington is truly a medical marvel.
Jack Skellington is a collection of bones without
connective or protective tissue, held together
in large part by a suit, possibly with stitches
securing his jaws. You wouldn't think that makes
for a particularly durable body. Yet Jack gets
hammered by cannon fire and escapes with little
more than a burned Santa suit. At another point,
he leaps around Oogie's projectiles and traps like
a bona fide gymnast. And even if Jack had been
hit, he probably would have come out feeling fine.
Take the movie's final act, for
example. The Pumpkin King is
blasted out of the sky by the military
and springs back up almost immediately,
even retaining enough strength and power
to return home and save Santa Claus and
Sally. Perhaps there's some truth to
the idea that you can't die twice.